did you make it through all the eight
years of full house
without getting loaded or did that start
no that was i was still a kid yeah and
like it really wasn't until high school
which is kind of when everybody starts
you know that's the time 13 14 15 like
you start doing dumb [ __ ] because
everyone's doing dumb [ __ ] at that age
um
but you know i
my
i always say i would have had issues
with addiction regardless of growing up
on tv
i understand addiction in a very
different way now but i also you know i
was adopted at a very early age
my parents both had addiction issues my
biological parents
i was raised by two totally normal
people and i
that was what i found you know i started
partying in high school and i was the
one that it was like i started and i
couldn't stop and i went too far and
people were like
yeah what's wrong with you i was like
i come from a long line like on my mom's
side of the family every single person
like without without exception yeah but
on my biological side it's a you know
there was a lot of addiction there was a
lot of
mental illness but you know coming
actually finding out now as an adult
there was also a lot more
success in some of my biological family
than i than i knew about but you know it
was
i definitely was born with
you know
a predilection to that and then at 13 14
you start going like who am i
where am i from who are my people who i
know these are my my parents but i'm not
from them so like how do i connect with
that and when the only thing you know is
like your parents were addicts and had
issues in and out of jail and
my dad was killed in a prison riot like
you know
when that's what you know
suddenly you feel like oh is that
all that i am is that who i am and i it
took me a long time to get over
that resentment and that hurt and that
all of that that really led to a lot of
my how old were you when you found out
you were adopted
when you were adopted uh i was
officially 14 months old but it was
right around like my first birthday a
little bit before so it was about a year
was there a period in between getting
adopted and not being with your
biological parents where you were like
shuffling through the system uh i didn't
get put in the system thankfully but uh
my mom was in jail when i was born
i talk about i was born in jail
technically uh at the usc county uh sure
on the you know the inmate floor but
yeah third floor yep 13th floor
and uh
you know there's like the kick and then
there's
right
yeah
so you know
luckily my mom had um
and and my biological dad had friends
who
and cousins and family who actually are
related to my adopted dad and that's how
i became adopted by my parents was
he knew of
me
through his ex-wife's family and his his
kids from his first marriage who were
actually the ones that brought me home
and so i was staying with them and
my parents really wanted to have kids my
mom wasn't able to
and they knew that i needed a home and
so i was really fortunate in that i
didn't wind up in the system because
right family and friends showed up for
me and took me home yeah but i
was real close you know and and i
i always look at my life as this series
of like
incredibly fortunate events where i just
happened to be in the right place at the
right time and like my life took
a really different journey you know
i think that's a great perspective
because i can imagine some people being
like man i [ __ ] got scrooge i was
born in jail and then okay
and you know here's the thing is like i
had to get through and you know i talked
a lot about that in my book unsweetened
and i
talk about it a lot because i think
for one thing i know that uh you know
growing up as an adoptee there was
i think it's there's less of a stigma
now but when i was young
you know my mom was always like we don't
want to talk about this because
they were afraid that
all of that coming out about me that
somehow people would look at me
different
and now i'm like i don't give a [ __ ] how
people look at me like you know i mean i
am who i am and i i
i've survived you know i've had some
obstacles thrown at me but i've also had
some really wonderful experiences so
that's life right like you sometimes
start off in a shitty place and then and
it's not so bad it's called stevo's hot
sauce for your butthole and if you go on
amazon and type in stevo's hot sauce for
your butthole and order yourself a
bottle you'd be really helping me
because right now we're ranked number 30
on all of amazon and if you buy a bottle
we might go up the ladder and that would
mean a lot so please get on amazon and
buy stevo's hot sauce for your butthole
yeah
yeah dude